new at six tonight Nellis Air Force Base
is a vital part of Southern Southern
Nevada it brings five billion dollars
and thousands of people to our Valley
however it used to be in the distant
Northeast part of the valley it's not so
distant anymore so what happens as the
civilian population grows closer to
military operations John langler found
out
Nellis Air Force Base is rarely quiet in
the sky and in the meeting room we can
if you will cuss and discuss through
those issues together Colonel Josh
demotts is the base commander we've got
a body that meets with the Mayors as
well as the county once a quarter but
I'll tell you that's really not enough
four times a year Nellis leaders meet
with Clark County North Las Vegas and
other local governments they discuss how
to be good neighbors we really try to
work and figure out what's best for both
worlds because we have to coexist by all
accounts they do but it can still be a
challenge to balance the needs of
civilian life with the needs of military
activity when it was first built in 1941
the Las Vegas Army Airfield was nice and
remote in just the last 35 years the
base has been surrounded on a
residential over there that probably
really shouldn't exist anymore because
of you sit in somebody's home and heard
it Rattle and it's uh they're doing
their training exercises I don't think
anybody into that
I know there have been some proposals in
the past for some potential uh
residential areas further to the north
uh that would be kind of underneath our
flight paths to keep civilian and
Military worlds safe and separate there
are guidelines like these the outline
planning around Nellis industrial is
encouraged homes are not what might get
in the way of military operations and
what the military actually needs we want
to make sure that we're not only safe in
the air but everybody that's underneath
us is safe at the same time there are
ongoing issues with infrastructure and
housing around Nellis we have Las Vegas
Boulevard kind of going right through
the middle of Ace I would love to have
80 90 million dollars to build a bridge
from one side of the base to the other
but it's just not realistic it's the
search for realistic Solutions which
keeps civilian and military leaders
engaged to everyone's benefit it is on
us to ensure that they can coexist John
langler eight news now